you kind of upregulate one of the  energies as needed in yourself rather  than living in only the ego or rather  than in living and only the divine well  they all need the divine is I most like  what it feels almost escaped when you  just escaped into some cave and I'm  Elias and just be in some audio Nirvana  or you know I mean that's you know and  some level I find that the exit  spiritual bypassing the extreme to  escape the world yes rather than  anchoring the divine force and year for  a reason and do our work and contribute  yeah and engage and not escape from life  that's the let's stay there again  contribution mmm-hmm so a lot of our  meaning or our actualization comes from  contribution providing the world with  some value that we can then reflect back  on and see the tribe has said thank you  for this value that you have brought to  us in terms of service